are you confident with
the nominee that trump has chosen amy
coney barrett
i think that um
i think that what he did with choosing
her
is brilliant
because i have only read opinions from
people
on the left about her only
because you can you can read you can you
can have
you can have people validate your
thinking all day and on sundays
so i only read pieces from people i read
one from
from somebody who clerked with her when
she was at the supreme court with scalia
and he basically said that another woman
who's now
the dean of stanford law school and her
were the most accomplished brilliant
jurists
of that class and he said
i don't agree with 99 of her views
but you cannot take away the brilliance
of her mind
and her work ethic and her understanding
of the law and you know it was it was
interesting
because if you go back to kavanaugh
to the kavanaugh hearings which were
just a circus
people with agendas again and you see a
speech by susan collins
republican maine she gave a speech
that i made my 16 year old read the
speech from the beginning to the end
and she said i did my job as a senator
i went and met with him i went and read
through his cases
and his decisions and this whole thing
what saying he's
you know some right-wing crack job look
at his work
look at his body of work you are wrong
and she's saying this to the senate
this witch hunt is inappropriate for
what we're supposed to be doing we're
supposed to be deciding whether or not
this person is a jurist and capable of
being
on the supreme court and so
if nothing else whether it's trump or
his advisors somebody learned a lesson
from that
and they got somebody who is
bulletproof what are your
do you think she'll i mean we're 31 days
out 33 from an election 33
33 days out do you think that there's
gonna a vote will be held
i if there are no skeletons in her
closet
and it does not seem like there are then
there's no reason that there would be
that there wouldn't be an expedited vote
now the risk is
the risk is the constitution does not
cap the number
of justices at nine the cap in the
constitution is 15.
and that's why during the debate a few
nights ago you kept
hearing trump press biden on will you
stack the court
will you stack the court why won't you
give your list of potential nominees
that's what he's talking about believe
it or not he's read that
that particular portion of the
constitution because i don't think our
president's read most of it
but he understands that element that if
if if the senate is taken by the
democrats
they can come in and increase the size
of the court to 15
such that the court would only be
quote-unquote stacked
and right-leaning for a short period of
time when's the last time it was more
than nine
never but it could go to 50 fdr it's
never been more than nine but that's the
it started off as six okay that was back
in
back in the 1800s and then it shifted
over to nine
but again the cap in the constitution is
15.
so why has it never been over nine it's
well it's
it seems like when things become habit
they become habitual
and that was just what it was and how it
stayed and you've always
had a balance um fdr threatened
when he was in office to stack the bench
and to increase the number
because fdr had a lot of a lot of his
own energy
anyways this is a pivotal time in u.s
history
and we should be paying very close to
what happens now
but also whether or not we're going to
see
the constitution itself by our
politicians
be used legally what about the whole
merrick garlic
merrick garland argument meaning they
nominate them it was 10 months out now
it's
60 days out they they're not they
nominate amy comey barrett like
again this was this was unseemly
it was arguably the wrong thing to do
but that has never stopped our president
and or mcconnell or mcconnell and
when the shoe was on the other foot the
votes weren't there
so they were able to push back right now
they've got the votes they've got the
ammunition so they can push it forward
here's a question for you who does this
help is this helping trump's reelection
chances or is this helping by
of course this helps trent look if this
thing you can
you can count ballots in wisconsin up
until november the 9th
there are there are more than 250 open
lawsuits right now
regarding the election going on
throughout the country
biden's got his army of lawyers trump's
got his army of lawyers they're all
fighting these cases
if if it's going to be thanksgiving
possibly or maybe into the
into december before we have a decision
if there is a chance that the supreme
court
as was the case with bush is going to
decide the election
then it's really what's happening with
the supreme court is way more important
than
anything else if it's going to go to the
highest court in the land
why do you think it would help biden in
this case no
you asked the question i'm saying why
would i don't oh why would it yeah why
would it like why we
why'd that even why would it help is the
people that are so worried about roe
versus wait if there's ever a time for
you to come out and
show up this is it you know if you
really want to fight for that like you
have to realize hey
the campaign on the left should be we
have to win house we have to so let's
just say he gets the supreme court
the campaign's got to be if we win house
if we have senate and we have presidency
then we can increase the 9 to 11 and we
can put in two no two new supreme court
that's exactly right we can so the
campaigns got to change from that angle
so i think this is an opening for them
to campaign better and sell it better
there's a many opportunities
to use this as a way to market and help
themselves many if biden came out and
started to outline who was going to be
in his cabinet
you know he could get people's attention
because everybody knows that it's not
going to be just that one man
i mean that much is known